vous tombez bien c'est l'heure de la
croque vous allez voir ils sont voraces
des galets voilà maintenant là c'est
vraiment le monde je préfère c'est lors
de la bouffe parce que c'est un peu
comme un comme un enfant à qui on donne
à manger qu'on va grandir c'est vraiment
à ce moment là qu'on s'aperçoit s'ils
sont en bonne santé ou pas s'ils sont
vives s'ils viennent sur la nourriture
et ils sont presque tous près de la
glace ça c'est qu'ils ont envie de
croquer alors la bouffe elle se
décompose de la manière suivante je leur
donne des des moules parce que ce sont
des poissons de mer alors donc je leur
donne des moules haché fin de la saâne
parce que c'est pour reconstituer un peu
là la verdure qui n'ont pas dans
l'aquarium et puis la nourriture vivante
des verts et d'ee à retenir vivants sont
des espèces de deux tout petits
invertébrés qui sont vivants voilà alors
on va procéder un distribution en
principe ils sont assez bourrin alléno
grohl
c'est ce qu'a stein là sont pas contents
parce que c'est de pression qui sont de
la même espèce
alors s'est lui hissé huit chefs c'est
une chef de l'appareil hommes c'est lui
qui fait la loi
ben ali est bien
en principe de la nourriture il faut
leur donner à manger il faut pas que il
faut pas que la nourriture normalement
doit pas tomber au sol elle doit être
avalé avant de toucher le sol parce que
sinon elle pourrit elle s'en va sous les
coraux et poissons peuvent pas la
récupérer elle pourrit et n est pas du
lot de l'aquarium ordonnait personnes
il aime ça la verdure c'est ce qui fait
plus d'efforts dans un aquarium que
c'est très difficile d'avoir des algues
j'avais eu une poussée d'harry
l'aquarium étaient complètement vers les
halles vont tout crever en huit ou dix
jours et les poissons sont nourries si
picorent les algues et bouffe ça leur
donne certaines vitamines
alors quand ils pédaleront en place des
halles par de la salle anne une canne la
vitamine d
j'ai tourné quelques verres va voir ça
les verts alors par contre les apprécie
une voiture vivante
c'est un art rond aérostatique us d'un
poisson qu'on trouve dans les merdes
reçues indienne il a la particularité de
se gonfler dans ce qu'il a peur il se
gonfle pas en principe si tu veux il
avale de l'eau et ils triplent son
volume ce qui fait que les prédateurs ne
peuvent pas l'avaler
ici tu as un poisson qui est assez rare
qui est un cri du russe qui fait partie
de la famille d'état ma cantine et en
suisse celui-là c'est un poisson qui est
malade tu vois si on le cadre
suffisamment gros doit percevoir sur les
nageoires des boules blanches ça c'est
un poisson qui a attrapé un virus
mais la manière de le guérir il faudrait
pour ça que je puisse la trappe et dans
l'aquarium ce qui est impossible parce
qu'il ya des caches partout et koro il
se planque avec un coton et du
mercurochrome je n'enlèverais ccc bull
et là y'a pas de problème et si tu veux
là ça donne 50 50 où il guérit tout seul
ou alors il guérit pas y meurent et les
autres poissons de bouffon assassin
baliste c'est un poisson qui est très
intéressant son nom scientifique c'est
le baliste fuscus sa passion qui est
assez agressif ans il a une espèce de
dare est comme une épée ça se dresse
comme ça et il se coince entre les
coraux et tu peux pas de sortir c'est
imprécis va sortir ils font qu le plus
les gens qui capturent ce genre de
poisson sont forcés d'envoyer dans l'eau
un somnifère
la seule boisson là c'est ainsi d'un
balises conspi si l'homme c'est un
poisson qui est le même que le bailli
fuscus qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est
la perle avoir glissé un des poissons
les plus rares et les plus difficiles à
trouver
il a une particularité c'est qu'il est
particulièrement intelligent c'est un
poisson qui fait la loi c'est lui qui
détermine le territoire des autres
poissons parce qu'il est plus fort il
est plus costaud il a une bouche tu veux
doté de dents on les voit des toutes
petites banques qui sont très très
acérées et poissons en ans
particulièrement peur et un truc qui m'a
qui m'a vraiment stupéfait quand je
nettoie la ville de l'aquarium j'ai une
espèce de paiement qu'on met dans la
flotte c'est pour éviter de professer
maintenant l'eau et jeux balades mon
élément comme ça sur la vie et il arrive
parfois que les mentons ben et c'est
très difficile d'aller le récupérer
puisque l'aquarium est assez profond
bien le baliste lui y voit léman et qui
avec son nez il le pousse comme ça et il
vient de récupérer sur la glace qui
permet de récupérer sans mouiller les
mains et ça c'est un exercice que je lui
ai fait faire plusieurs fois donc c'est
pas si tu veux fortuit c'est vraiment de
l'intelligence il ya une complicité
entre eux entre l'homme et le poisson et
il a eu un regard à une acuité à suivant
extraordinaire quand j'arrive avec la
nourriture j'arrive de la cuisine il est
à l'autre bout l'aquarium
il me voit il se déplace il se met dans
le coin il me fait une danse comme ça il
fait 10 de la queue et il avertit que
les autres poissons que ce genre de la
bouffe pour lui le premier bouffés il
fait la loi si un poisson qui me bouffe
et avant lui le bastonne les eaux dans
mon père
ma dernière acquisition c'est celui-là
c'est un danger qui s'il ya risque fait
partie de la famille des paumes acompte
idée c'est un peu particulier il ya dix
jours et comme tu as pu le voir lors du
party cette impression qui est adulte
alors je trouve ça un peu dommage tu
veux qu'on pêche les poissons adultes
parce que sur le nombre de poissons qui
sont arrivés à paris une arrivée six
comme ça il y en a eu trois perdus ça
fait quand même 50 % de déchets sont
s'aggrave parce que on peut pêcher des
poissons qu'ils soient jugés ni des tout
petits poissons ne sera pas une grosse
importance parce que toute manière ils
ont une chance minime de s'en sortir
dans la mer mais des gros poissons qui
sont maintenant des reproducteurs tient
alors voila voila c'est vraiment dommage
quoi c'est tout moi je suis contre cette
forme cela dit je n'ai pris parce que je
trouvais tellement bon j'ai pas pu
résister envie de lâcher
et les prêts et primes jugent
difficilement parler du bois parce que
ma femme me jette un petit oeil noir
les prix savary ça varie suivant les
services suivants et bresson pour donner
un ordre de grandeur ça peut aller de
2500 francs le poisson à
afin d'apprendre les moins chers enfin
disons que dans la moyenne se situe
entre 300
400 fois walou oui c'est comme c'est pas
un hobby très bon marché aux poissons
ils viennent ils viennent à peu près
partout de toutes les merdes l'océan
pacifique l'océan indien madagascar
l'île maurice
et philippine bangkok ça me permet de
rêver un petit peu quand je suis le soir
dans mon canapé je regarde puis je
voyage un peu et mes poissons
ce qui est très important dans la
décoration c'est de pratiquer des caches
qui est beaucoup de cash et des zones
d'ombré de lumière parce que le poisson
il n'aime pas toujours être en pleine
lumière en plein éclairage il a besoin
par moment d'être au soleil d'autres
moments de se cacher par rapport à
d'autre poissons qui le chasse il faut
faire beaucoup de trous de l'endroit où
il peut se cacher ce qui permet d'avoir
plusieurs espèces de poissons qui sont
souvent pas compatibles les unes avec
les autres
tu vas dans cet aquarium je n'ai pas que
les poissons qui s'entendent bien
ensemble mais c'est possible par le fait
de mon décor où les poissons peuvent se
planquer lorsqu'ils sont pourchassés ça
c'est un des principes de base de
l'aquariophilie c'est de faire un décor
dans lequel peuvent ce plan
si le décor n'est pas scellé doivent
pour la plupart des cas lance maintenant
dans cet aquarium presque partout le
décor est scellé avec un ciment c'est du
syntt offert chez ces trucs qu'on met
sur les carrosseries de voiture il se
tient très bien il ya des endroits où il
est passé d alors par exemple ici en bas
de l'aquarium
ils bouffent les lébous de coraux il les
amène il est transporté ils
reconstruisent le décor alors façon ce
sont des bâtisseurs c'est son aîné de
balises que j'ai qui se banalise
s'emballe en tant que votre balai comme
des chiens et les mouscronnois bush puis
ils travaillent ils vont se faire une
cache
alors tu fabrique-t-on haute mer abeille
je fabrique mon autre merde tu veux
l'eau de mer elle est fabriquée à partir
de l'eau douce au début de
l'aquariophilie marine
on était en eau de mer naturel c'est à
dire que tu faisais venir de l'eau de
ces en atlantique ou de la manche bon
alors maintenant on a des sels minéraux
qui reconstitue l'eau de mer à peu près
parfaitement et que c'était qu'on
n'arrive pas à avoir des éléments comme
le plancton qui sont relativement
nécessaires à certaines espèces de
poissons qui ne peuvent pas vivre sans
plancton alors sur des poissons qu'on
évite d'avoir en aquariophilie mari
tu es venu à l'aquariophilie un peu par
hasard que je me demande si roman d
alarme à 10 ans
après plusieurs déboires de poissons qui
mouraient pas ce que je faisais pas mal
de bêtises
je me suis passionné plus en plus pour
pour ses poissons et j'ai eu envie de
d'avoir un aquarium plus grands alors
avec virginian s'est mis à chercher
maison qu'il ya un pan de mur
suffisamment grand pour pouvoir placer
cet aquarium et en est tombé sur sur
cette maison ici à vernouillet n'avait
donc il ya tu mets un point de mur qui
fait 5 mètres de long un royaume fait 4
mètres 50
il contient à peu près trois mille cinq
cents litres d'eau et donc on a fait
qu'on soit là quoi rallier de l'aquarium
est alors pour le placer ça a été un ami
n'est ce pas parce qu'il est venu livrer
c'est à dire tous construits et il
faisait une tonne de à vide sans rien
donné et puis je me suis rendu compte
que c'est un aquarium plus grands
c'était plus intéressant parce que les
poissons se développe en fonction du
volume cubique
dos dans lequel ils sont alors à savoir
si vous voulez si vous avez un baliste
on a parlé tout à l'heure
moi je les ai eu tout petit j'ai eu et
il avait trois mois c'était un poisson
juvénile bon maintenant il a quatre ans
fait quatre ans que je lai il fait 25 cm
c'est un poisson qui dans 3500 litres
d'eau il atteindra une grandeur environs
de 35 ou 40 cm
donc je trouvais ça plus intéressant est
maintenant dans le futur j'aurais envie
d'avoir quelque chose d'encore plus
grand que 3500 et mon rêve ce serait
d'avoir un aquarium multifaces cinquante
mille litres d'eau que la maison soit
pratiquement construite autour
d'aquarium et je puisse avoir des
poissons alors énorme des mérous des pas
des poissons de tout ça je voudrais
faire subsiste un certain d'arriver à
faire un aquarium où je puisse mélanger
les invertébrés et les poissons parce
que tout ça vit en symbiose iskra un
équilibre extraordinaire part ça c'est
très difficile à réaliser parce que
d'abord ça coûte une fortune et que
d'autre part les gros poissons mangent
au fur et à mesure les
les invertébrés alors c'est
pas facile parfois je sais pas peut-être
le futur
l'aimant liquide chez soi c'est un peu
comme le feu tu vois c'est agréable
d'être autour d'un âtre de regarder une
cheminée flamber ce un spectacle dont on
se lasse pas tu peux regarder le feu
pendant des heures et des heures et un
côté hypnotique et ce côté hypnotique je
retrouve devant mon aquarium avec les
poissons parce que parce que cette
bouche parce que c'est vivant parce que
c'est perpétuellement en mouvement suit
en somme si tu veut le témoin permanent
de de la vie et en dehors de ça il ya le
plaisir des yeux parce que c'est bon un
poisson moi personnellement je trouve ça
beau et gentil je suis très attiré par
tout ce qui se passe au fond de la mer
parce que ces mystérieux et puis aussi
un autre élément si tu veux dans la voix
de fille que j'aime c'est ce silence